The team,
both Nathan nationwide investigation,
but the Guardian reveals for the first time what really happens at journey's
end.
Whoa.
That sounds like a m night Shyamalan movie.
Right?
That kill a bunch of homeless people like Satan's involved.
It's like they just moved them away.
What did they say?
Where are they?
Ship them.
I don't know.
Looks like this.
Throwing them down in Miami and in La.
Oh,
well I lives in Colorado.
In Colorado.
People would hold,
his people would commit crimes.
They figured out what crimes they would get 60 days for.
Okay.
And they would commit that crime,
plead guilty.
Do the 60 days just to get out of the winter
because of those days.
Boldly would give you tobacco.
You were alive,
they would give you tobacco,
but you had to roll it.
That type of shit.
A Boulder County jail in 1991 boulder county jail and some other jail.
We're voted number one and two jails in the country.
Wow.
That people would want to go to those jails.
Then boulder built the new jail and it became fucking commy.
This lamb like aspen Cardenas land.
Yeah.
Like no cigarettes.
Everybody had a way.
Uniforms no more staying up till two in the morning when I was around with the
other way.
Boulder County jail the way.
What was good?
The good way up?
Boulder County jail.
It was a paradise.
Well,
what was wrong with that?
It got out.
It got out that it was too nice.
Right?
So like I'm telling you,
homeless people would commit a crime to do 60 days.
Can I ask you something guys?
There's a person who's been in jail.
Go ahead.
Would it motivate you more?
This is an honest question.
Would it motivate you more if you were in jail and it was nice and comfortable
in there and you got to relax and calm down or would it motivate you more if
they brought you into some communist type jails?
You described it with everybody.
I'd wear uniforms.
There was no cigarettes,
there was no fun.
They eliminated your outside time,
but I did.
I did them both.
What would you think is a person who's been through what would be most effective
in rehabilitating you?
I mean that's the idea,
right and rehabilitative right now.
You said to me,
you got to stay this fucking building for six months.
This is going to be a jail.
There's like Pablo Escobar's jail.
It's still jail.
I want you to remember that you can not leave the building for six months.
I will let you go out to the front of the cage one hour a day.
But you got to figure out what you're going to do with the hip at 12 months.
It's a cage.
Yes,
I have more options here.
I can lift weights,
do different parts of my body.
I could shoot pool,
blah,
blah.
Boulder was very simple.
Boldly,
you got up,
they gave you the letters.
You either took them away,
get it.
Now I want to get my own cars.
So you called home at lunchtime.
Joe Rogan brought me my jeans,
my sneakers,
my tee shirts.
I'm wearing my own clothes.
So now that determine what you were in for a nonviolent and violent.
If you're in London,
violent offender,
the world is yours.
The violent ones,
the ones that get lumped in together.
So now the violent offenders,
uh,
depending on what you do as violent,
you go into one sector and that sector,
the longer you're in to have and the more rewards you get from,
if you're in green,
you stay up till 10 and they got cable TV.
If you are red,
you Steptoe 11 and they got cable TV.
If you're purple,
you stepped on a one 1:00 AM,
oh my God,
both.
The county jail was tremendous.
So I didn't drink milk.
Milk is big in jail because the body builders like milk.
It's like fucking drugs.
So I would trade you and you my milk for your Koolaid.
All right.
So I was in there drinking fucking Koolaid because I fucking hate them.
Boulder was a paradise compared to other jails.
I don't listen to this Thanksgiving day when I was locked up tax every day.
Yeah,
the guard came in and I'll never forget his name was Ron and he opened up the
south door and there was a phone that,
I think it was anybody who needs to use the phone.
He was the phone.
I figured out,
you know those days you had a press mind,
they got an outside line.
I pressed eighth to see if I get long distance.
Nothing that breast seven,
six not been fired for fucking long business.
I got the call,
my peeps in Jersey for 20 minutes a piece.
You know,
you just figure out different days.
Then they sent you to a place where somebody looks you in the eye and says strip
down and you've got to go take a shower.
And then you come out and they put a finger up your ass to see if that's
contraband.
Ooh.
And they,
they give you a tidy whities and orange show,
put like a rubber glove on and then loop different her up.
It doesn't matter at that point I didn't give a fuck you putting a finger up my
ass.
It breaks you down as a man,
as much as anything in the world.
That's the first breakdown.
Wow.
The turn you around to let you know they run you,
they're going to stick it up your ass and you go to Esl and that,
those guys,
and they're not very nice.
They weren't like the Boulder County jail guys.
Those guys would kick your bed and make you get up,
try and get light on the middle of the night and say,
get out of bed.
We're going to do a search at two in the morning.
Those people are not nice at all.
Then I got transferred to Summit County jail,
which was a fucking paradise.
Paradise.
Paralyze him bull all day outside TV till two in the morning.
He freezing yourself,
black and white TVs and yourself.
Basic cable.
You could be up all night if you wanted to go to breakfast,
you ate breakfast.
If not,
you could sleep through breakfast and we'd eat your breakfast for you.
And then from there they shipped me off to the Department of corrections.
That's where it's the nitty gritty.
If you think black people talking to a movie theater at night,
don't go there.
Don't go that black people talk all night.
It's six or seven floors and I was in there in August with full humidity canyon
city,
Colorado.
Wow.
All right.
With a little window,
you know.
And that was like on the third floor.
I couldn't read and in those days they let you out.
You can Ku showers a week and one hour a day.
You went outside after that you would just in a cell by yourself at night or
froze the daytime.
It was like fucking being sweating in a fucking 10 can.
You wouldn't attend Canada the
that way from this name Charles Shit.
There's nothing to showers and then the three meals and then that,
and then the first week is good because you actually get out of your cell to go
test.
They tested everything.
Your math,
your English,
they fucking put a bunch of pictures of in front of you and they put you to
psychiatry.
They take your blood out,
they do everything and then they assess you and then they have,
I took care of all of the dots.
Okay.
There's a bunch of dots.
You have to,
you have to dot your i's like if you have a high school diploma,
you get a point.
If you were working at the time of arrest,
you get a point if you were up to paying rent.
So I got a bunch of points for that.
It's so funny out.